-Performing "Go In Light"
featuring Monica Martin,
from his new album
"(self-titled),"
once again, Marcus Mumford.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Cry havoc in the evening ♪
♪ Sirens in the morning ♪
♪ Peace by the afternoon ♪
♪ I was planning on leaving ♪
♪ Unless you really need me ♪
♪ I'm just trying to
keep up with you ♪
♪ Here in my wildest dreams ♪
♪ We are the only ones awake ♪
♪ The memories stop ♪
♪ And you call my name ♪
♪ Here in my wildest dreams ♪
♪ Where the eyes fade away ♪
♪ The memories stop ♪
♪ And you call my name ♪
♪ Go in, go in light ♪
♪ Go in, go in li-i-i-i-ght ♪
♪♪
[ Applause ]
♪ I know that I'm walking
a treacherous line ♪
♪ There's breath on the glass ♪
♪ But death on the vine ♪
♪ Havoc in the evening ♪
♪ Silence in the morning ♪
♪ How is it so loud ♪
♪ When it's quiet? ♪
♪ Here in my wildest dreams ♪
♪ We are the only ones awake ♪
♪ The memories stop ♪
♪ And you call my name ♪
♪ Here in my wildest dreams ♪
♪ Where the eyes fade away ♪
♪ The memories stop ♪
♪ And you call my name ♪
♪ Go in, go in light ♪
♪ Go in, go in li-i-i-i-ght ♪
♪ Light ♪
♪ Light, li-i-i-ght ♪
♪ Light, light ♪
♪ Light ♪
-♪ Light ♪
♪ Go in light ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]